uh sonata
you came your story is you came from
bosnia
why don't you share with us briefly your
story well
we actually have a lot of a lot in
common in that regard
um i lived through the war in bosnia in
90 1922 i was a teenager i was 13 years
of age and
saw more atrocities and horrific things
than most people will will see in their
lifetime
and i worked for the united nations at
the time and
and got a chance once in a lifetime
a chance uh to come to the united states
to study
and you know we were refugees during the
the war in bosnia
um we lost absolutely everything i also
lost my father
and it was you know a pretty big deal
for me to come to the united states
because it paved the way to
help all my family to come here were you
the first in your family to come to the
united states wow yes i was the first
one i came with 200
in my pocket and a scholarship which was
cool
pretty cool and worked really hard um
ended up getting my undergrad degree
moved to new york
i worked in healthcare venture capital
and then got an opportunity to work for
donald trump
so it was the most unusual experience in
that you know i'm an
immigrant i'm a woman right um
i used to be a refugee and coming to
work in the big city
um was pretty awesome that's why i have
such a soft spot for new york i love new
york so much
in that place people welcome you with
your differences with what you have to
contribute right
and after being there for about five
years
six years i decided um
they're meeting with trump organizations
yes yes so after being in new york with
the trump organization with trump
international
in particular i decided it was time for
me to
have a little bit of an easier life
because working
let's say 80 hours a week is good for a
few years
expectations that's the experience 80
hours a week easy
and after you know doing that for five
years you come to a point you're like
okay
i need to relax a little so i moved with
blackstone when they bought the boca
resort and moved here to boca raton and
i love this little place
and i used to get teased a lot by my new
york friends like boca raton
like seriously it's such a would they
tease you about it it's a sleepy town it
was known at the time
13 years ago as the retirement community
and it's so not that
um so if you move to boca raton you're
going to have to deal with that as well
yeah i mean that's what they told me
when we were coming on you but
honestly we came here the way the way
they described it was the best
say miami you got palm beach okay
you can even go jupiter if you want to
pace and speed of lifestyle
more south faster more up you know
slower yeah i like a little bit of pace
but not too much
bokeh is a good place to be in the
middle exactly pacing so
so you're saying so you work with trump
obviously directly you guys work very
closely together was he a pretty
intense high standard guy himself he was
and was he like one of those guys that's
always
on where he'd come in to work he was
also working hard himself he wasn't just
expecting to work hard was he also
always working hard himself he was
always working hard himself
so you know i we would start at like 7
30 or so and i'd be there until 10 30 11
and um we call him mr t so he would come
in in the morning to see who's there
who's who's the first one in the office
where
what time would he get in the office i
don't know eight o'clock
eight o'clock step it up donald trump
i've already been in the office for
three hours
buddy not you adam not you step it up
don stop it not you
adam's a 9 30 guy after you do your yoga
that's with my yoga yeah you relax well
what time did we start today
at 7 30. so how am i at 9 30 guys we
started at seven days once a week you're
here at the
twice a week what's it twice a week the
podcast the podcast i gotta give it to
you you respect so ever since you
started working here we got you coming
here at 7 30.
and that's a big deal for florida pat
you know you know
i tell people from new york all the time
if you come down to florida
and you keep that new york mentality
that hustle that you're going to kill
the world yeah because everyone in
florida i'm sleeping in i might go to
the beach today
i'm hungover you're funny i was on a
yacht yesterday
or you actually were on a yacht yeah i
was hungover yesterday that's what i'm
saying like
yesterday was rough now i'm back in it
but yeah you understand like
i totally get it am i wrong on that or
am i you are
so so let's go back to so trump was a
hard-working guy who expected his people
to also work hard
yes what did you learn from working
because when you work with somebody like
that for five to six years you're gonna
walk away
picking up a lot of stuff what were some
of the things you took away from working
with them
a few things but number one was i
remember when i first got there in the
office there was a plaque that says
start from the end
and it took me a few seconds to
understand what that truly
means but he is always like get to the
point
and he never had the time to listen how
you got to a certain point it was just
like start from the end
[Laughter]
you know what so this is a recording
they made because adam will go and say
some stuff and i'll say what's your
point
and then we got a button yeah now we got
a button for it so he would say get to
the point
get to the point and it trains you how
to think differently and that's what
happened to me
i immediately get to the point and then
it would be like what's your suggestion
because
coming with problems to him was not
optimal come with what's your point
and what do you suggest another thing
that i learned to like figure it out
uh which is if you're tasked with
discerning for me it was trump
international
i worked with a company called bayrock
if you were tasked with figuring out
who's going to be your target market for
trump so
how do you get highest price per square
foot and everything had to be the
highest the best
you know the most glamorous and
everything so
you would go into this process of what's
it gonna take
and the standards were so high that you
knew
if you just you know come up with a
little report and he hated reports
you'd have to tell him you know it's the
russians who will want to pay the
highest price per square foot
why not because of the location but
because of the brand this is what you
need to do with the brand so
it was really interesting
for me at least coming from venture
capital
to real estate development and real
estate marketing in particular
how to understand to maximize the value
of a brand
to achieve maximum price per square foot
interesting
and the other thing was which i think
translated subsequently to his political
arena was no your know your people know
your
audience and if you tried to
target very specific audience who
already loved the brand you just needed
to focus on them you didn't have to
worry about
trying to sell to someone else so
specific niche work on a niche that you
had
very riches in the niches you know the
whole um okay yeah
so those those were like some of the big
big lessons and
and the other one was always beyond you
know i i used to work
from whenever i woke up didn't even have
time to train you get ready you could
get to the office you work
you go to grab a bite to eat at like six
o'clock
and oftentimes he would pop in at like
10 30 to the office to see who's still
there
at night and i remember
i remember one night in particular i was
really tired i was working on a project
in phoenix so
i had taken the red eye and i was at the
office it was like 10 o'clock
i was exhausted and
you know just kind of okay let me just
finish this
and he came by the office and we're all
like okay um
he's like you don't have makeup like why
do you look so tired
and i'm like well i've been you know
working hard
he's like get it together finish and go
home wow
so like disrespectfully or no it wasn't
even disrespectful
it was like just an observation i didn't
take it disrespectfully but it was like
you always had to be on think about it
think about it so just so you know he
got his work ethic and his hustle from
his dad
but he got a swag from his mom his mom
was always on
and his mom always had the expectation
that you gotta like
the swab you know the swagger was a mom
thing i don't know if you've seen his
mom's hair
you know hair do what it looked like her
she had like a bouffant
yeah like pretty much so if you look at
that that's a great word
have you ever seen him not look put
together
yes when there's a lot of photos of him
looking
sloppy when when have you seen sloppy
sloppy dogs when have you seen him being
sloppy
you don't see that if there is photos
it's because there's billions of photos
but the guy is pretty much
granted he's always suited and voted
you've got to take tan and so we get it
did you ever see him negotiate or no
did you ever actually witness him
negotiating yes uh what was a style
uh the same what you've seen in the
white house i mean he's really like just
get it done he doesn't care how you get
it done um
very intimidating like i honestly i've
never seen him smile
during those five years so that's you
know he's very very serious
uh very intimidating um and
he would listen but he would only listen
to people he trusts
so people who are in his inner circle
including his children
got it and did the people that were in
his inner circle did they stay there for
a long time or would they
churn and burn kind of like politics no
okay so on the business side they would
stay with them for a long time on the
business side from his
assistants to people who worked for him
were there for decades got it last
question for you about him
driving how did he drive people like you
know uh uh there's
different ways people drive their
teammates their staff their sales people
what was his style
um i would say fear based in a way
yes because he would have really high
expectations so if you
fall beneath whatever that high standard
is
it's like you don't belong there so
it not as many carrots in that
you know he thought that
people should pay him to work for him in
a way
so um many people
stay there for quite a long time because
once you're in that inner
circle there's the you know material and
financial
benefit do people make money working
with them like if you would stay with
them long term you're going to make
money
yes so you have to get through a certain
threshold and certain point in order to
to make money so
i don't think um it's just the
environment was really stressful it was
very competitive
um but i think i learned a lot from it
and for me like i'm not afraid i live
through a war so
unless someone has a gun to my head i'm
not afraid of you
um do you kind of need to have that
thick skin to even be in that
organization
absolutely like if you're not really
ready for criticism or to work hard like
that's not the place you should correct
got it correct um question
seems like you had a beneficial
experience there were some pros and cons
and you worked hard
and but overall it was a net positive
right and you've
worked pretty closely with him i mean
you're saying you'd be in the office
working at 10 p.m and he'd
show up and you interacted with him
um but you're also an immigrant yeah you
know you
live in new york city like you have
clearly a love for
diversity and inclusion and all that
stuff
how much how shocking was it when you
saw the switch from businessman donald
trump to
politician donald trump you're like oh i
can see that or you're like whoa
i don't even recognize this guy where
did you where'd you go with that that's
a really great question because
someone who's seen the business persona
for all that time
when i saw the political persona i was
not shocked at all
and i actually knew how he is
and that he would polarize the country
that was very obvious because
um he has very strong very clear like
set of values what's important to him
and how he is and how he thinks so
if you know how he thinks you know how
he's going to act
in whatever arena he's in so um
i it was really difficult for me that
yes my experience
working there was a net positive but
as an immigrant as a woman it was really
tough for me to see
um some of the statements not some many
statements that he's made and even
what's happened in the capital and
you know but it's not shocking to me
because he steers the path
he likes that yeah he enjoys that
he i i'm not surprised either i mean i i
you just watch him at apprentice he
steers the pot his entire career is
about to stare in the potluck what do
you expect him to do he's going to
continue stirring a pod
um but you know kudos to you
for your story to go from bosnia to come
to new york to work for trump
organization five to six years to come
over here
after your father passed you've
experienced all this different mess and
you come and
you see what's going on with america
right now sonata how much
do you love america i'm curious i can
answer that for mine but i want to hear
from you how much do you
love america from your perspective i
love it what do you love about it
what do you love about it i love the
freedom okay i love the freedom of
speech
i love the fact that you can be an
immigrant you can be a woman you can
speak with an accent but not think with
one and
make it in this country you can be an
entrepreneur i love that what does that
mean speak with an accent but not think
with one
i i say that because i've never heard
that before you know you get
underestimated
when you speak with an accent that's at
least what i've experienced
and i i joke about it and i heard that
from a good friend of mine who's cuban
and i i really took that on it means
that don't underestimate me
i like it i think people here with an
accent and a third one that can do any
accent
her and i have an accent we give you an
accent you do a german accent for us
isn't that crazy i tell you
um do you want him to do accents but
don't forget we also have other accent
boy here
that's that's a bruno accident yeah
that's that's like my gay german bruno
thing going on that's a pretty nice
kai actually speaks uh with a
thick norwegian accent but he fakes it
because he wants to well he feels like
an american guy let me hear some
norwegian oh my gosh some norwegian or
norwegian accent
all the above the accent from norway
i moved to uh florida and now
i live here well you can do it good for
you
no it's that's how they speak no no
that's that's i think that's that's if
bruno were from norway yes
then she just she just called you out
bro by the way guys
shout out to kai talent he's behind the
scenes
so since we're on the topic let's just
wrap this up since we're on the topic
because i'm curious by the way
somebody's asking a question here
daniel estacio i'm going to get your
question here matter of fact i'll just
ask her right now
her advice to florida realtor and her
favorite books
for realtors wow um advice to florida
realtors
is give it your all
it's it's a crazy time and i think just
work really really hard right now
um and be prepared save all your money
because we don't know how long this is
going to be here you say save that money
save that money no seriously so so
working because
so save like you've never said before in
today's economy absolutely
some some people love to spend when when
the money is there but i just say
save all your money be very be very
very careful how you plan for your
future because
you know nothing lasts forever it's
crazy i'm buying a house right now and i
know i'm not buying out the best market
and i know that what does that feel like
knowing that they're buying at the top
of them
but i know like we just had a
conversation right off
off-camera about you know whether you
buy structure you buy land all this
other stuff
and we have a good team i think we're
pretty clear on what we're looking for i
think everybody is managing expectation
well
and we will see what's going to be taken
let me ask another one last question
just
before because i know we're going to
move on no no just on real estate in
general
so take off your 25 million dollar hat
and put back on your 700 000 hat right
you said that's okay
so what advice do you have for our
audience who are you know maybe they're
buying a first-time home
and you know maybe they're not in my i
mean maybe they're anywhere just you
know we talked about the list
who should be buying a place right now
who and who should be like look
maybe you're renting like give advice to
the half a million dollar buyer
million dollar buyer real quick not the
25 million dollar buyer absolutely
that's that's a
really good question in that you know
most people
feel that real estate is their highest
asset
right like the highest valued asset so
when you're making that big decision
it's a very emotional decision not just
financial
i would say be logical not as emotional
about your purchase look for off-market
opportunities
that's a big one because most people
just look what's on the market right now
i use your resources your connections
your
you know people you know to look for
things that are not even on the market
um because there are you know things
change unfortunately in our business you
know divorce is one of the major reasons
for people to
want to change their home situation so
i would say regardless of the price
range but 700 000
definitely finance because the rates are
so low look for
good opportunities knowing that it's
it's about the value so if you decide to
sell in three five seven or ten years
that you're going to be able to sell
your property and not regret your
decision
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye